anh
không biết mấy ông ngồi đợi tôi lâu
không nhưng mà tôi ngồi đợi mấy ông từ
hôm trước rồi
Ờ và một tiếng trước 1 tiếng trước nãy
giờ không có tiếng Vừa rồi tôi chỉ ngồi
Cốt lại mà tôi chuẩn bị kỹ lại việc đó
của mày sẽ giận như nào phải cho hôm nay
là lần chuẩn bị nhất của tôi chúng tôi
tự tin từ tự tin nó hôm nay dậy một cách
chua chanh sợ trôi chảy quá rồi nhanh
quá Nếu mẹ bảo lại như đa cấp nhưng lại
giờ
nếu mà hôm nay Ờ tôi đã giật giật Tít
thông báo mới ông ấy đó là mày Tôi sẽ
dậy rất là dễ hiểu rất là ờ ờ
anh nói chung à Chúa Trời tôi khẳng định
không phải rơi trời
giống đa cấp mình đi bây giờ thì đương
nhiên là Nhưng mỗi khi bây giờ mình sẽ
chuyển vào tâm sự tí tâm sự mà nhiều vậy
từ thực ra từ hôm trước trợ từ trước ghi
lại đã phải nói thêm trước rồi
thì cái đầu tiên tôi muốn nói
ra cái này là quan điểm của tôi
Ừ ừ
bạn di kia cũng vừa hỏi có giờ 2
khi họ claire phiên bản nào ở
khoa học Neville chính xác đó là hồi hồi
mà tôi dậy ở trên trường ấy nếu không
biết nó dậy phiên bản nào Hồi đấy à
hồi hồi đấy là Lazio nó nó từ 6 rồi 7
giờ 8 tối vẫn chỉ dám dậy ở chiến trường
là 5.6
8.6 thì phải không phải
5555 đổi lên thì phải 5 6 thìa nhầm sang
phiên bản tt nhau nhưng mà nói chung là
hồi đấy bởi vì tại sao như thế bởi vì
tôi mới chỉ chuyên 1 fat burner phiên
bản đấy Thôi tôi không Chưa ấp cho kiểu
thực hành quen với Lara phiên bản cao
hơn tôi không
Tôi không dám dạy Isarel phiên bản cao
hơn và ghì à Thế là nó cao hơn thì nó sẽ
có thêm những cái hàm mới chứ nó cũng
khó loại bỏ những hàm cũ đem về Đang
chạy được rồi Thì
đấy thì còn bây giờ tôi đang ở trên công
ty thì hiện tại công ty thôi Đang dùng
level 8 thì chả là tôi sẽ dậy được mấy
ông Tám có thể anh có thể thế bởi vì
thực ra là công ty của tôi là kết hợp
rare với views nghĩa là file sẽ làm bằng
da Switch chứ không phải là pp Blade Nếu
là chắc là tôi cũng sẽ phải tôi tôi cũng
đang phải suy nghĩ vụ đấy đây tôi sẽ
không biết được vào tôi có nên kiểu ở
chắc là tôi vẫn phải lại ngồi để mà
làm lại một lượt cài thử chạy thử trên
máy ngon lành đã cho mấy hướng dẫn với
ông Tài cài đặt và chạy được đến mấy ông
có thắc mắc gì thì tôi còn gặp vấn đề
đấy tôi còn giải đáp đối ngoại Cái quan
trọng ở đây đó là mấy ông gặp vấn đề gì
tôi phải giáp được còn nếu mà tôi không
giải đáp được thì sẽ bản thân ăn mấy ông
sẽ thấy nản khi mà thấy không trả lời
được thì trò nó trả lời được chẳng hạn
thế nên là tôi vẫn sẽ phải thử chạy
trước đã đúng ạ Thôi bảo rồi tôi tôi sẽ
đồng hành cùng mấy ông đúng nghĩa đen đó
tôi sẽ đi trước ngoạn tôi ở cái chỗ nào
khó đi thì tôi sẽ dặn trước với ông ấy
Ông cẩn thận và tôi sẽ đưa lời khuyên
Vân Vân Nghĩa tôi đi cùng mấy ông nên là
tôi không phải là tôi à
và
tôi chắc là sẽ khiến con đường nó nhịn
hơn một tí trong mày không đi chứ chứ
tôi không thể làm khiến cho kiểu tôi
cõng mấy ông đi theo được nó không phải
là kiểu của tôi cố kéo nhưng mấy ông mấy
ông sẽ phải tự giác đi thôi đó ngoại
quan trọng là tôi sẽ người dẫn được cái
mày không phải quan điểm mà như thế
khóa học cơ bản thì có trên kênh của
mình rồi đấy thì bạn xem trên đấy thôi
xăng redleo Ừ tôi đang định là thời gian
Nếu hôm nay mà nhanh quá thì có thể hôm
nay đã xong được cảm ở shopee chúng tôi
nghĩ là hôm nay mình nên nên đơn giản
ông tí đó là mình ok Một bạc trước đã
xong rồi hai bản sau thì chắc là phải
buổi 6 nữa thì mới sang Lào ra để ngoạn
anh Bởi vì thực ra tôi tôi dậy hôm nay
tôi đã dậy ạ bắt đầu dạy nó có tí Khá
nữa bạn ở biết ride cơ bản rồi thì bạn
đấy Sẽ thấy hoài Hôm nay anh dậy Ok
giống khá khá giống rar rồi đấy tôi tôi
dạy Oppa không bắt chước tôi bắt chước
mỗi người một tí tôi xem trên mạng rất
nhiều Mà hồi mà tôi được học cũng thế
Tôi sẽ cố làm theo tông theo kiểu dạng
là khá giống giống lario để mà khi mấy
ông nhảy sang Al Nếu cảm thấy bỡ ngỡ gì
cả bà nó cũng sẽ không giống như ở trên
mạng nên là mấy ông mà bảo là sao anh
không dậy giống ABC Z thì thì không tôi
dậy theo kiểu để mà nó làm mô hình của
rare hơn là một cái mvc Thuận An
ờ ờ
không có tải đâu Cho dù hôm nay thì đúng
là nhiều cái nước nhiều tôi không không
khẳng định nó khó Ừ nhớ mà nếu mà góp
hết chung vào một buổi thì nó sẽ thoáng
nếu mà hai bạn thì bởi vì hôm nay cũng
rất là nhiều file rồi nên tôi nghĩ phải
hai buổi
ờ ờ thực là hôm nay
anh cũng là một cái hôm trước thì tôi
bảo là mày ông có thể bọc hai buổi Hôm
trước bị hôm trước rồi con nó khá phức
tạp nhưng mà buổi hôm nay thì thuê mô P
là mấy ông sẽ thấy nó dễ hiểu hơn cho
bữa hôm trước nghĩa là mình mình học
buổi đầu nó sẽ hơi rất là khó hiểu
Nhưng mà Mấy ông không được làm cái quan
trọng như thế mấy ông mà thấy khó với
ông đã làm thì cái ngày nó ra nó nó
không theo được Nói thẳng như thế cái
ngành này là phải là khó Mình hỏi mình
phải cố thêm nữa
rồi cũng sẽ thấy nọ bớt khó và nóng sẽ
quen thôi ví dụ là kiểu Nếu mà Mấy ông
mà xem một hôm trước không hiểu không có
nghĩa Hôm nay không đi xe mà buổi hôm
nay ông xe không sẽ hiểu được cả Bố hôm
trước ông sẽ thấy dễ hiểu hơn một hôm
trước tôi thể tôi sau đó khi mà tôi nhận
dậy sang Lào leo ấy thì mấy ông còn thấy
mấy cái la gio nó dễ hiểu nhất so với
cái Đồng Nai nhưng mà Đấy là do là mấy
ông họ trước mình đã đúng này rồi nên
ông khi nào nó dễ hiểu méo gửi cho
tuần tới hiểu hay nhiều
Ừ nhờ đại khái thế nghĩa là kiểu à
Ừ cái ngày này nó không
với ông này này dễ cả linh tinh Tôi chỉ
nói là ai cũng nên học ngày ngày đúng ạ
Ai cũng ăn nhưng mà để học khóa các bạn
nhé còn quá nâng cao á khóa trên sâu này
thì tôi có khuyến khích mấy ông họ cho
vui không đúng ạ người ông thực sự là
theo theo cái
theo ngành này hoặc là mấy ông muốn kiểu
nói chung là ngày này hả nó chứ không
phải kiểu làm chơi cho vui chơi vui thì
cái khóa cơ bản đủ làm trong các cơ bản
rồi à
[âm nhạc]
nhờ có thầy Hiệu phó kia nói chung mà
còn khóa chuyên sau này là tôi hướng đến
cho các bạn đang theo ngày ngày họ là
muốn theo ngành này để đi làm được Nếu
Chắc chắn là nó mấy ông không thể nói là
kiểu lương nghìn đô ngày ngày Dễ Nói Thế
thì không đến lượt mấy bọn mình đúng
không đấy thì tôi sẽ phải cô hướng đến
không hẳn đã đến hẳn lương nghìn đô
nhưng em ạ sẽ ít nhất ít nhất của cái
khi mà làm xong được cái đồ án của khóa
này thì ông phải được Junior thức trả
lương 7 8 triệu rồi Và thậm chí à Nếu mà
ở về sau tôi dậy thêm nữa để Chuyến sau
hơn nữa để nói chung là toàn bộ những
cái gì cho biết thì béo phải lên được
Suneo và Lương phải 15 triệu đồng ý nhất
lại đi nha tôi sẽ có hướng với ông mình
như thế thì
ở cái thời gian mà tôi đã theo từ hồi mà
tôi
bắt đầu học là từ 52 đi cho đến bây giờ
ra năm ấy nhé 20 tuổi hai mươi tuổi tôi
giờ hai năm rồi Ở nghĩa tầm 55 tuổi học
ngày này rồi mà tôi đang cố truyền tải
cho mấy ông trong vòng vài tháng thì mới
ông sẽ biết ở cả lượng kiến thức nó rất
là khủng và nó cũng như thế nào đấy thì
nhưng mà tôi tự tin là cách truyền đạt
của tôi nó cũng cũng tương đối để trong
mấy ông không không cảm thấy kiểu dạng
mà bị sắp quá nhưng mà đương nhiên nó
vẫn sẽ làm một lượng lớn nên thành ra là
mấy ông sẽ
Ừ đấy do có video ở xem lại không ạ mấy
ông sẽ không không thể nói là ngày một
ngày hai thấm được hết đúng ạ ạ
tuyển nhà rất nhiều nhà Tuyển dụng sẽ
Honda thôi khẳng định luôn kiểu gì sẽ
mời nhiều nhà Tuyển dụng tham gia rồi
các thứ các thầy nữa xong ngồi à ri dê
thì thôi đã gửi cho mấy ông có cái link
để mấy ông xem có GD ở trên Linh đi có
rồi ở trên Sony có tôi có chia sẻ cái
Linh mày ông thể vào để xem các gd là
các yêu cầu của các công ty tuyển dụng
rồi nó đang tuyển dụng nhân sự như nào
mới không thể đăng thì ra mấy ông thể
nộp đơn bây giờ cũng được nhưng mà tôi
Nghĩa Ông cứ học xong chán chơi đã rồi
ông ông theo anh chàng cũng tỉa Ok anh
Em đang đào tạo Em đang em đang giả vài
bạn ổn sẽ về công ty mình ạ anh ạ cái
đấy tính sau ta nói chung mà kịch tôi tự
tin là bên này tôi cam kết được đầu ra
ổn thế nhưng với điều kiện là mấy ông
vẫn là theo được không ạ Nó không rẽ nó
vẫn khẳng định là nó không chị xem top
để chém gió nó dễ được nhưng mà
Ừ ông đang theo ngành này thì thực sự
thì tôi cảm thấy à
nên tin tôi đã
so
với nhiều nơi có cam kết đầu ra được như
thế đâu ạ
sự là để tâm sự cuối cùng sẽ chẳng nói
được cái gì cả
à à
Asha đâu
nhưng mà biết rồi ra Swift được cao nghệ
sóng view sẽ vẫn được ở
Xin chào bây giờ đang hơi bị hết thời
gian tâm sự rồi mình sẽ chia sẻ qua về
cái vụ mà đại học thăm cụ này của mình
Ngày hôm trước
ngày hôm thứ
ngày đầu tuần hôm thứ hai vừa rồi thì
tôi có đầy đoạn cốt sai lỗi chính tả lên
vợ một cái đoạn ngớ ngẩn gì đó sai lỗi
chính tả lên rồi vì tôi lỡ viết tắt cái
đoạn đấy lại không để ý nó nó đoạn code
ở như thế này
Ờ Ờ
nếu mà chỉ như này nó đúng như này nó
đúng để xem nhẹ sự tôi cho biết nick ở
trên
bằng nha đi
a
MT à
a cho một biến y đáy cũng như này đi à
đúng nhá
thi cái này đáng lẽ là tôi định là nó
như thế này nhưng mà hôm đấy tôi viết
tắt và tôi biết ngầm ở thành như này
thành an lỗi và cái lỗi ở đây thì cái
lỗi ở đây cái ý em nó đang báo rồi nhé
mày
Ừ cái yêu nó đang báo cáo nhé lắm tôi
không để cái lỗi mà báo là đằng sau dưới
này cơ Nó ra cái này bảo là thiếu cái
dấu hai chấm đấy khiến o tôi kiểu đầy cô
đoạn này lên tôi cứ tưởng chỉ cảnh báo
nó không hề báo lỗi gì cả bởi thường báo
lỗi này sẽ báo lỗi thì cùng màu đỏ gần
ngay cơ thì nên là tôi đẩy Cốt đã để lỗi
lên và đương nhiên là cái đoạn lỗ để làm
liên quan đến cổng thanh toán chết nên
là công ty ở qua đây cũng cậu không
thanh toán được từ 12 giờ đêm hôm trước
sau rồi cái thứ hai bị dính Tại sao lại
bị kiểu mặt bị như thế nữa đó là cho là
hôm trước không Đấy vài ngày thì cái
kênh lỗi đấy Ừ nó bị sao ghê quán cái
lỗi khác
Ê bà cái lỗi đấy Không phải lỗi của tôi
Tôi làm không phải không Không phải bên
tôi làm đấy nghe tôi tạm tắt cái thông
báo của cái kênh này đi Sau đó thì bà và
anh em thì ra cũng không dùng snack nữa
anh em chuyện có dùng discord này cũng
chẳng để ý gì kênh snack nó cứ bật lỗi
thành ra là cả đêm hôm đấy nó bắn lỗi
không ai biết được ngày hôm sau một phát
hiện ra
thì nói chung là mất nửa ngày đặc biệt
là bởi vì thị trường tôi làm bên châu Âu
và Mỹ nữa thành ra lúc mình đang ngủ lúc
người ta bắt đầu kiểu giao dịch thanh
toán nên là thiệt hại thì
ac3 les trăm cũng phải Xe nói chung là
tôi sẽ bù tiền lương của tôi thì giờ tội
chẳng có tiền mặt những đại khái thì cái
bài học rút ra ở đây nó là thứ nhất là
đương nhiên nên cẩn thận lại vụ đấy Đảng
ấy lúc đấy tôi kiểm tra lại tôi phải
phải đúng theo quy tắc nhiều cái kiểm
tra nữa nếu mà có ông biết thì nó sẽ là
có thêm những khái niệm và unit test để
kiểm tra về cả lỗi chức năng A kiểm tra
việc chạy lại chạy lại
an toàn bộ một tính năng gì đó để để xem
tính năng này còn chạy được hay không
Kết quả nó ra hiển thị phải như thế nào
đấy trực tiếp theo là có nhiều cái là
slipper kiểu như này là thêm những cái
để mà nó sẽ kiểm tra về lỗi chính tả hay
kiểm tra thêm một vài cái lọ na ná giống
như là cái á cái mà tôi vừa nặn cho bé
uống xem ở đây đôi khi nó sẽ thông báo
cảnh báo gì đó chứ không hẳn là thông
báo lỗi gì cũng có đấy thì
em
và
nói chung mà còn rất nhiều các bài học
rút kinh nghiệm rồi đấy Nếu không có thể
hiểu những cái quan trọng là cái tôi
muốn nói thêm đó là thứ nhất là tôi
nhiều nhiều người thì mẹ thôi chả sẽ đổ
tại ở riêng số rồi lại đen rồi tại năm
nay mày đen tuổi đen vân vân tôi không
mở còi mọi thứ như thế do duyên lại gì
cả do bản thân mình thôi Thì chắc chắn
mình phải rút kinh nghiệm với mình còn
trẻ mình vẫn còn bồng bột quá Công nhận
Nhiều lúc tôi rất bồng bột cốt song đôi
khi ở tôi không kiểm tra kỹ lại tôi sẽ
phải cẩn thận những cái việc đấy và cảm
thấy cái cái giá này ra mình vẫn còn chả
được chứ không phải là em chẳng phải ông
sẽ biết rất nhiều cái vụ ngay Việt Nam
Đó là chị sai cốt kiểu như thế mà đền
đến nỗi là mày không phải đi tù không
lên được mày không hiểu không thì mấy
ông cũng phải cẩn thận vụ này không phải
lỗi về dirt mà bất kỳ ngày nào nhỉ Khi
mà ông đã đền cái ngưỡng nào đó nó làm
ảnh hưởng đến cả công ty thì ông vẫn
thấy bóc lịch mà đúng không nên là không
phải mỗi ngày này đấy thì
nói chung à không không phải nói là thế
Tôi không theo ngành này nữa tôi chọn
mày là Mày ít chịu trách nhiện không
chẳng nói anh nhà như thế cơ à Ông là
một mình mày cũng chịu nhiễm ảnh hưởng
ấy khác còn không thì kiểu gì sẽ trải
nghiệm ảnh hưởng thì cái thứ hai tôi
muốn nói Đó là
cái mai nữa Có cảm thấy may ở điểm đó là
công ty tôi thử ca vẫn đang trên đà phát
triển vợ công ty sát Vẫn đang vẫn vẫn
đang kiểu đanh đá phát triển lên chứ
không chưa đến ngưỡng là kiểu dạng là
dụng giao dịch hàng tỷ
tỷ đô ngày các thứ khi chết được phải
không biết đêm Điều gì có thể xác định
là không để đền được à
Ê bà đấy Cái tôi nói cái may đấy nữa thì
đó là mấy ông và cũng thấy xa lắc như
mấy ông còn được quyền sai những cái lúc
đấy Ông còn được quyền sai và được quyền
sửa và ông có thể học hỏi chứ có những
cái lỗi lầm ông vào công ty lớn Ông sai
cái thì chơi hẳn luôn
cho mấy bé ông hiểu gì cho nên là đấy là
100 điện cái tội thằng bảo là nếu mà khi
mấy ông đi thực tập mời ông chồng có
nhiều thí nghiệm thì mới ông nên và con
thì Shop sẽ vừa được học hỏi vào đây tôi
còn nói thêm chúng vào máy nữa được sai
lầm Hãy tội cảm thấy tụi mày thì sai sợ
say sớm thế
Ừ mai mà khi sớm thì tôi nghĩ là có thể
biết đâu về sau mình sẽ sai nữa mình
không sửa cái tính cách này của mình và
hôm ấy thực ra không phải mỗi giúp kinh
nghiệm mà tôi mà tôi tin là những anh em
đẹp ở trong công ty tôi cũng thấy được
cái vụ đấy và cũng cũng cảm thấy
anh cũng phải rút kinh nghiệm làm cái gì
đó trong việc à chồng việc cẩn thận hay
ở trong việc kiểu
ở đây tôi bảo rồi đấy Đó là kiểm tra về
kênh kênh thông báo lỗi các thứ thứ cũng
như là
nói chung và bài học của cho tất cả thôi
Ê hồi trước Và tôi từng xem một cái bài
học nữa cũng của bên A Nice lát à Đó là
kiểu mày không biết bài học về chưa nhỏ
đó là kiểu data pay bị
cái cái tôi tôi nhớ không lầm đã Tâm bây
à à
a
gutless sập
ở đây xóa nhầm data7 không phải sập nữa
đây
bỏ
lỡ vô tình chạy cái này ngay trên chính
trị hơn 300 dữ liệu 300 GB dữ liệu bài
đúng không đấy mất hoàn toàn dữ liệu của
6 tiếng đồng hồ này không thể truy cập
sau trong suốt 18 tiếng lại xảy ra sự cố
nha quá trình khôi phục lại như thế nào
nhưng Cái quan trọng là mấy công ty lớn
này luôn có tuyến phòng vệ rồi nhưng
nhưng đó là Nhưng cái phòng vệ này đều
bị chết
số Bưởi hoặc là lâu không để ý nên nó đã
bị chết cái gì đây này như thế này Cắt
giảm chi phí và chủ quan là cái này là
đủ nên không kích hoạt tính năng này sau
đó thì cơ hội cuối cùng là gì cho Vân là
gì nhiều cái thứ Nói chung là mấy bạn
đọc bài này hồi hồi mà mình chưa biết về
tao bay mình đã hiểu đã đọc cũng dễ hiểu
trên này Đọc sẽ dễ hiểu để có thể tham
khảo nhưng mà Đấy nghĩa là ấn chỉ rồi là
mình sẽ phải có những cái bát pháp gọi
những cái dự phòng ngoại và và Minh có
phải thỉnh thoảng phải kiểm tra cái dự
phòng đấy bởi vì đây là chủ quan này
nghĩ rằng à Anh
dự phòng dự phòng nhưng thực ra chẳng ai
đấy cả chẳng ai kiểm tra lại cái dự
phòng với cả hàng ra sẽ dự phòng đấy nó
cũng chết nếu hiểu thì thôi
trọng là em
em nghe em em Nếu mà thật sự thì còn
khắc khắc dấu ghi tâm thì hơi khó đó là
tính cách đấy nhưng mà chắc chắn là mình
phải cải thiện tình lại cách này đặc
biệt muốn làm được trình viên mình phải
cảm nhận rất tỉ mỉ cẩn thận
Nhưng mà ok
tâm sự vừa đủ rồi đấy Cái bài học của
tôi như thế Tôi hi vọng với ông không
dính mà
những bài học của tôi khá đắt không dại
gì cả nhưng mà mày vẫn còn chả được và
sẽ còn cho từ từ trả trừ dần vào Lương
Thế tụi bay mất thưởng thưởng của cản cả
năm nay rồi cả năm sau nữa à
ai ngờ Mấy ông mà mới đi làm mà Mấy ông
bị thế thì sẽ không biết làm đúng không
ạ Ừ Ok hôm nay thì mình sẽ sang mới xài
Ok nhưng mà ờ ờ
lại cái ảnh mà hôm trước mình cho các
bạn xem bởi vì hôm nay nó sẽ thay đổi
một tí cái một tí về cái mô hình đấy tao
mở mà em xem nhé
anh cái ảnh hôm trước là đây không ạ
Nếu nhiều ngày không ạ Nếu mình nuôi dê
là không ạ Alo quyền quyết lấy lại bình
tĩnh Để Mời ông vào luôn nhé
Hôm nay cốt dài phết đấy Nên là mấy ông
cũng cũng nên xem vào xem cốt chứ nếu
anh xem qua màn hình tôi khẳng định với
ông không hiểu gì không à à
thì các bạn nhớ về cái vụ này không ạ
việc là khách hàng đến xong rồi Lúc đầu
đưa cái Menu
sau đó thì kiểu gọi món xong rồi thì
thằng Nhân viên nó vào gọi đầu bếp để
đầu bếp lấy bò la rồi chế biến sau đó
trả về bò xong rồi chả vậy đĩa thịt bò
cho khách hàng không ạ Nhưng hôm nay
mình sẽ thêm một cái nữa đó là nếu mà
một cái nhà hàng chuyên nghiệp một nhà
hàng chuyên nghiệp với người k0 có một
đầu bếp có một nhân viên như này đúng
thì nó sẽ là gì nó sẽ thêm một thằng
thằng quản lý Đông ạ
ngày trong trường hợp này thằng tăng
trưởng này tôi sẽ gọi thằng này thằng nó
khái niệm ở trong nourish trong leo nó
Khánh nó gọi thằng này sẽ giấu tơ rất là
thằng điều hướng đấy à a
router root root router Tôi sẽ gọi nó
router A thì thằng ai sẽ nhiều hướng hay
có tác dụng là gì Nó như tôi đã nói nó
giận nó phù hợp và phòng quản lý hơn tất
cả chỉ là khi mà khách hàng đến
Ừ thì À thì nó sẽ gọi cho thằng thằng
quản lý rồi xong quản lý sẽ kiểu điều
phối hàng nhân viên phù hợp và thằng đầu
bếp phù hợp để mà làm cái thứ mà bạn
muốn Giả sử nhát Giả sử Nhưng mà ví dụ
trong lần này ông đến ông đến ông bảo là
tôi muốn ăn đồ à Tôi muốn ăn
bò bít tết kiểu tại của Âu chẳnghạn cá
thứ không phải là của châu Á như cửa bò
né mà cậu kiểu cổ Tây đi không ạ Gọi
Beats fake cả đấy Kiểu thế thì nó sẽ dẫn
nó sẽ phải bảo mới thăm thằng nhân viên
kiểu thằng bồi bàn kiểu dạng dành để đổ
tây ra để nó sẽ chuyện cho ông cũng như
là phải có một đầu bếp kiểu chuyên về bò
bít tết Tây chứ không phải là kiểu
chuyển bò né không ạ này thì thì sẽ là
như thế
Ê
mày cũng chỉ tôi không ạ Nghĩa thằng
router sẽ tặng điều hướng thẳng điều
phối sao cho là để phù hợp với các yêu
cầu của khách hàng của client đấu ngoạn
rút à à
tôi sẽ có 1 file file này pp và tôi sẽ
gọi đến thằng router
Thực ra trong trong mô hình mvc thì sẽ
không có cái router này ở trong mô hình
Thuần nhưng mà trong tết trong level thì
có nó thêm cái đấy nên nên là tôi mới
mới cho nó thêm vào đây để khi mẹ mấy
ông nhảy Sang Woo cũng sẽ hiểu
tôi sẽ có săn router vậy đúng không ạ
sẽ để hết toàn bộ bảng tên biến bằng
tiếng Việt một vài cái tiếng Anh thôi để
cho mấy ông dễ hiểu nhé à
Ừ thì bây giờ
cái cái đầu tiên mình cần làm đấy Đó là
thi tôi mới vào trang web này thật sự
như này tôi mới vào trang web Bây giờ
tôi tôi làm trước một bảng thì tôi sẽ
làm trước bảng lớp nhé bằng lớp của tôi
chỉ có mã với tên thôi hai cột Tôi tôi
muốn đầu tiên khi mà mới vào Tôi hiển
thị ra toàn bộ danh sách lớp có mã và
tên ở đây thì mình cần làm như thế nào
mình sẽ cần nhúm trước mình làm là mình
sẽ là gọi là controller lớp sau đó thì
mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ danh sách lớp ở trả
về đúng không Nhưng hôm nay làm theo mô
hình kiểu mới xe kết hợp với oppa tất cả
Lập trình hướng đối tượng rất là đầu
tiên là ông sẽ phải làm hay sao đầu tiên
là nước như ông vẫn sẽ gọi đấy Hằng
container rồi tôi sẽ gọi phần trả lời
nhé
Ừ tôi sẽ khai báo đây là bởi vì vì sao
tôi biết được là vì sau sẽ còn rất nhiều
controller nên tôi sẽ tạo hẳn một thư
mục thì cắt lông như thế này tôi tạm một
file Bởi vì bây giờ sẽ lập trình mô đồ
app tất cả hướng đối tượng Đối tượng này
là tôi sẽ đặt tên file nó nó chồng luôn
và cái đối tượng
cách đặt tên của thằng thằng là pp là đã
quy ước đó là nó sẽ là viết hoa toàn bộ
chữ cái đầu đông ạ Chứ không phải là
viết theo kiểu mặc đà không phải viết
theo kiểu là con rắn là cách dưới nữa nó
sẽ viết như thế này nó sẽ ở lớp cắm cho
l
mở file đúng không Rồi class lớp
controller như thế này bởi vì đề Đối
tượng nên nó sẽ gọi khai báo kiểu flash
xong rồi phó mặc nhọn như thế này nó một
đối tượng
mấy ông sẽ thắc mắc là tại sao ở trong
thư mục controller rồi mà lại phải đặt
tên file là lớp vẫn trở lên nữa thì cái
này lại là quy ước của thằng leo tự
nhiên là ký ức như thế Tôi không rõ
Nhưng mà thường là tôi cũng thích theo
kiểu này vợ kìa nếu mà ông dưa ông đang
dùng pass tôm này tôi thường anh dùng
phím tắt là dùng 2 lần phím ship thì sẽ
gọi được đến 1 file nhanh ấy thì thì ông
sẽ đỗ ông sẽ gõ để cái file này khá
nhanh ở lớp vẫn cho lâu nha thì rất là
nhanh đấy lại và để phân biệt cho Tí có
lớp Model nữa thì tôi sẽ cho mềm xe ở
những đại tài Ok đã có một đối tượng rất
cần cho lời ngay đúng không Thì để gọi
được định các đối tượng này ấy thì mới
ông sẽ có khái niệm đầu tiên ông vẫn
phải vị phải wipe cái lớp controller đã
nhá p này
sau đó thì để ông gọi được đến đối tượng
này này thì ông sẽ có khái niệm là ngu
nó cắn cho l nhìn này đâu ạ
sau khi mà Miu này khởi tạo với đối
tượng lớp control được không
như bây giờ tôi muốn ở đây là tôi muốn à
em trả về danh sách lớp cơ mà đúng ạ Tức
là tôi muốn thằng cái thằng lớp con cho
lợn này sẽ có một cái hàm
cho hàm gọi là
Phong sinh
Tôi đặt tên Hàn là hàm tên là Index tất
cả danh sách để để trả về toàn bộ danh
sách lớp để không ạ ạ
ở đấy và cách để tôi gọi đến cái Hàn này
cách để tôi gọi điện máy hàn này thì tôi
sẽ thường là đây Tôi sẽ phải
Uh cho nó là mặc tròn như thế này tôi
gọi đến như thế này Index như thế này
thì tôi mới gọi được cái hàm index như
thế này đúng ạ ạ
à
mà trong hàng này như như giống hệt Hôm
trước mình đã làm thôi đó là trong hàm
index này mình sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ làm là
lại kết nối đến hàng mua đồ để mà lấy
toàn bộ lớp về bởi hắn mua đồ đã làm
việc với database mà không ạ sau đó thì
mình sẽ gọi đến view để mà trả về toàn
bộ kết quả của từ Model sang độ xong
view thì bên mình sẽ gọi hàng mua đồ thì
giống hệt thằng các Trailer này mình sẽ
tạo một thư mục còn mua đồ này sau đó
thì lớp như thế này chẳng phê nếu không
sẽ thấy là
cái đối với hàng lao ấy thì mô đồ nó
không thêm chữ mô rồi làm sao đâu chỉ có
tên của cài Office rách như này nó giống
như là
tên bảng thôi Nó tên bảng viết hoa chữ
cái đầu thôi không không thêm chữ s luôn
nhé Nó sẽ không thêm chữ f ở bất kỳ lớp
controller là hai lớp Model không có
thêm AD đâu nhé kể cả để tiếng Anh được
ạ nhưng mà không được Có thêm thêm s vào
lên nhá á
Ừ đấy Tôi sẽ tạo thư mục mua đồ này
các
bạn đấy sẽ
từ nãy đến loại này mày không thấy vẫn
trôi chảy đúng không Không tôi dậy trôi
chảy Còn mấy ông hiểu hay không ấy cạnh
Nếu
mày có thể một phát hiểu ngay được cái
hồi mà tôi học cái tôi còn chẳng hiểu
làm yếu không Nhưng mà chắc chắn là đến
đoạn này tôi khẳng định cô vẫn đang chơi
Trời
file này xong rồi mình lại bắt chước mà
mình sẽ khởi tạo ạ
thì mình sẽ khởi tạo với thằng lớp cân
lớp này để mà gọi đến cái hàm để mà lấy
danh sách Nó về tôi sẽ có một cái hàm là
tên Hà Ngô Tất cả lấy hết toàn bộ lơ về
trả như này
ơi con ếch này đâu có hót này
mày quen không
tôi đã dậy rồi gì trừu tượng đâu
bằng snack sao for love này à Cho coi
kết quả trả về vấn nạn này quen rồi đúng
không Nếu không quen thì quay lại làm đồ
ăn bột nha à
có phải quen không
từ hạt anh vẫn cho em bắt em thấy em tốt
hơn hôm trước rồi
Bây giờ Bây giờ mình sẽ khởi tạo cái đối
tượng lớp này sao mình sẽ gọi đến Hàm ô
để lấy tất cả về nhá Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
có
ma kết quả giải hạn mình tôi thường này
đặt là bị sút à à
mạng đi
đây sẽ có là nhiều lớp này à mà sao nó
gọi đến hãng ô để lấy hết về này chẳng
hạ thế
à nếu nếu em
đến đến là này hiểu rồi Đến Tôi tin là
đến đoạn này mấy ông hiểu nó nào rồi Thế
mình sẽ khởi tạo lại thằng Biển thằng
đối tượng lớp này sau đó thì mày ông gọi
đến cái hàm ô để lấy tất cả về thôi sau
đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ gọi đến một phòng
view xong rồi lớp rồi in rec.pro
mình sẽ tạo một thư mục làm thư mục view
khi
đặt trong thư mục đấy lại có một thư mục
đã dùng một lớp
cơ cấu tạo phinx chấm pp này
phanh này chỉ đơn giản là
một cái thấy bồ đây thấy bồ nha
mở
Ở đây lại cái điệp khúc I
sách thôi đúng không ạ
em
ở đây Tại tên này
tôi chạy thử mấy ông nhé
khi bạn lỗi à à
anh không tìm thấy file à Đúng Đúng rồi
Nội tội lỗi tôi bên này phải là control
xong rồi mới cho đến ok ok chạy này đó
đồ đấy
cái này tôi vẫn chưa dậy xong opelo cứ
bình tĩnh bình tĩnh Tôi vẫn đang dậy
đang từ từ đấy mấy ông hiện thấy hiển
thị ra hết chưa Đã đến đoạn này tôi thử
nó lại nhá
Em thử thử nói lại này à
ở đầu tiên là đi từ internet thì bỏ qua
Index của router là thằng rotor là sẽ
gọi đến hàng container bởi vì tôi đang
mặc định và gọi đến Hằng lớp controller
tí ở chắc là tôi sẽ về sửa lại là nếu mà
giờ sửa vì sau có sinh viên có sờ l hay
gì gì đó nữa đối ngoại thì sẽ phải gọi
đến thằng con trả lời tương ứng
à à à đó hả mũi tên đỏ đánh sao mũi tên
đỏ là như này à
em chưa hiểu gì em ạ à
Em làm ở để mũi tên nó chuyển sang màu
đỏ không cái này do template của tôi tự
động thành sông màu đỏ đấy
có vài cái màu mè mày bỏ quan à
ừ ừ
Đây nó sẽ gọi đến hàm index sau đó thì
bản chất Cái ham intek này sẽ gọi đến
hàng mua đồ số ngồi gọi đến Hàm ô để lấy
tất cả lớp về Đông ạ Đây thằng thằng bạn
chất thằng mua đồ này nóng sẽ đâu nhỉ
từ toji Cái này đưa luôn à
anh
chết luôn hả nhiều người vào xem quá
Á
Hậu ơi
mẹ ông thầy đó em à
xe máy trưởng ở ừ ừ
Ừ đợi tí trả tôi hãy cho bé ông và lại
vãi chưởng trên luôn ạ
xem cùng lúc file đấy quá Vãng hay gì đó
không biết được đâu là cùng bay ạ
ờ ờ
à Xong rồi gọi đến Hà mô này tham ô thì
giống như mình từng làm thôi có lấy dữ
liệu về không ạ nhưng thế này vẫn chưa
được tính là ok hoàn toàn tại sao lại
như thế vậy nhưng sao nhất à
từng tí tí một đã cho bé uống xem nhé Có
sẽ sửa từ file ôtô trước đi nếu không
thấy gọi đến hàng nghìn e cả đúng ạ gọi
để gọi được đến hàm index như thế này
bản chất cái này nó sẽ phải là public
funtion
sẽ khái niệm này cho mấy ông
nó sẽ khái niệm đó tích phong trần như
này thì nó mới gọi được đến Hà Minh đất
một cách
kiểu từ công lắp ních ở công khai nghĩa
là tức ở ngoài ở ngoài vẫn thể gọi được
đến Hàm đơn giản như thế này Tại sao
khái niệm ở ngoài Ừ thì mày ông sẽ biết
thêm với những cái khái niệm ở trong
Open nó sẽ làm public này một cách tập
này
và Private này Thực ra thì
Ừ cái này cho để tôi nói thẳng luôn là
thôi không phải là chuyên về Ok lắm tôi
không chuyên về không đối tượng nó lắm
Nhưng mà tôi tôi đủ biết qua về những
cái Hàn này nó
hôm không mở được
em có bạn vào được em ạ Anh anh chia sẻ
lại đây rồi đấy thì mẹ em lại phải tham
gia lại thôi à
đề thi thì cái này là nó công khai tự ám
chỉ là khi mà lưu như thế khi mà gọi
khởi tạo thằng đối tượng thì ông có thể
gọi được ngay hàm những cái Hàn public
Đúng rồi Nếu mà Mấy ông học bên Java rồi
thì mới ông sẽ rất dễ hiểu cái này nhưng
mà Mấy ông Nếu mà Mấy ông mới tinh giống
như cậu mới học từ tôi thôi Cái ông sẽ
thấy cái đoạn này nó hơi bị khó hiểu và
không phải khó hiểu mà chẳng còn nóng
mới mới nhiều cái mới quá
tiếp theo là còn cái vô tích cực phân
tích cực Tức là cái tôi nhớ không lầm là
cái này là gọi được ở trong những thằng
cái thừa nữa nhưng mà mình tôi không dậy
mấy ông người kế thừa tôi sẽ bỏ qua vụ
này đây tôi sẽ không dậy mình cái đấy
yêu nhá Mấy ông sẽ phải tự tìm hiểu thêm
sau bây giờ mà tôi dậy rất nhiều cái
bộ chuyên sâu về Ok thì thời K nói rất
quá tải xong với ông mà thậm chí là tôi
bản thân tôi Tôi bảo rồi Tôi bây kỷ niệm
cũng vài năm rồi Nếu mà tôi cũng không
Tôi không cần phải chuyên mình cái đấy
nên lên Nên là
nghe tôi nghĩ em yếu không cần phải nhớ
cái để lắm tôi Chị chỉ dạy ông Mười hai
cái thôi Thứ nhất cái template này điểm
gì kẹp iPad là điềm gì public là để mình
có thể gọi ở ở bên ngoài còn quay vết là
mình sẽ gọi ở bên trong cái class này
thôi đấy ông chỉ cần nhớ đúng hay đấy
thôi là được rồi nghĩa là trong trường
hợp này vì ông thấy ra tôi gọi ở bên
ngoài như này Thế bên ngoài bên trong
như nào bên ngoài là tôi khi mà khởi tạo
xong tôi gọi được bên ngoài nhé này và
bây giờ tôi sẽ chuẩn bị tôi sẽ có một
cái Private cho mấy ông để uống xe thì
đầu tiên là cái này là public ok rồi nhá
Cái ô này mấy ông thầy cũng sẽ thấy cái
này sẽ là plotnick bởi vì sao vì rõ ràng
là tôi vừa gọi nó ở bên ngoài như này
không ạ Thế còn quay biết là như thế nào
từ khi biết là mấy ông sẽ thấy cái khái
niệm Oppa ở đây để em gì không thấy hiển
thị ra toàn bộ công ty rồi ông ạ Nhưng
giả sử
em
giả sử là
anh về sau tôi muốn thay đổi thông tin
theo kiểu là tui ở đây vẫn là tên nhưng
mà ở trong Doctor bai của tôi lưu là họ
và tên này tôi sẽ sửa lại được tạo bởi
vì mẹ không xem
tô một tí
ở
à à
đúng rồi tôi còn chưa trả lời cái câu
hỏi mà có bạn hôm trước ta không không
vào được Pokemon khi cài la razon bản
chất là cài là ngon xong thì mặc định
TPP nin của nó lại ở trống Nên là các
bạn sẽ nên dùng các bạn ở đây các bạn
dùng cái hay đi whey này cho quen này
cũng được này
Vậy Và nếu mà bạn vẫn quen muốn dùng
tamani này thì các bạn sẽ phải lên trang
chủ của mẹ thấy femen tải về xong rồi
cài vào cái thư mục của loa Gold Thế nó
có cái hướng dẫn đấy các bạn làm theo
Còn nếu mà thấy hướng dẫn khó quá thì
thì không cãi đúng không Thì dùng tạm
cái kia thôi tôi thấy dùng cái dùng cái
hay đi này ngon hơn là hoa tôi quay ra
đây vì tôi chưa cài đặt cấu hình thì ở
đây cả
tôi không Tôi không hướng dẫn với ông có
rách cho tội không biết gấp và sẽ ra ở
cracklock nguy hiểm lắm nên thôi bây giờ
xử Bên mình có tên đúng không Thật sự
bây giờ tôi sẽ cho họ đi rồi cho thêm
một cột ở mạng sau cột mãi sẽ cột họ này
ở đây tôi là một giải thích mấy ông nhé
một cái là ngày
ngày đấy Ok thì bây giờ giả sử là cái
phần tên này nếu không thấy được ra nó
vẫn ra như thế này nó chẳng thay đổi gì
cả cho dù mình thay đổi bây không ạ
nhưng mà ở đây Biến thành thêm nhiều nhé
Thôi kệ đi thì ở đây tao muốn là khi mà
sau khi mà kiểu in ra đây Tôi muốn thêm
chữ ngày trước chắc chắn rồi Ngày trước
đây tất cả hoặc hoặc là tôi Tôi chỉ đang
ví dụ về đâu nhé nghe âm Thị Nở khi mày
in ra một cái gì đó là ông bản chất là
ông muốn khiển chị ra cái khác Nó sẽ có
khái niệm ở trong lập trình nó sẽ khái
niệm là ghét tất cả lấy dữ liệu ra ông
muốn lấy dự ông lưu lại là một kiểu như
không lấy dữ liệu ra là một kia tương tự
Thế có có thể đêm những cục là cột Ví dụ
ở bên bên sinh viên này thì ra đến sinh
viên đúng chứ lớp làm gì có họ không ạ
nhờ Giả sử là mình sẽ có thêm cột cột
giới tính ảnh ạ Các bạn nếu dây tình
không ạ giới tính mình lưu lại là 0 và 1
Nhưng bản chất là mình khi mình in ra sẽ
là nam với nữ rằng ạ ý tưởng tượng thế
hoặc à Mình lưu lại à Mình không như đại
tuổi người dùng lưu lại năm sinh người
dùng anh ngày sinh này dùng để hạn không
ạ nhưng mà mình in ra thì mình in ra
tuổi ông ạ Tức là mình lưu lại ở một kia
đúng ạ nhưng mà mình khi mình lấy ra
mình ghét và thì thì nó lại là một cái
thứ gì đó khác ngoạn Thế làm thế nào để
mình mình xử lý cái đoạn này đúng ạ Hãy
nên nhớ là mình sẽ không xử lý mấy cái
trường hợp này ở bên view biển view mình
vẫn sẽ phải giữ nguyên đến việc cái việc
chỉ việc đơn giải II nổ ra thôi mình sẽ
không làm cái việc là xử lý ở đây mình
lại mình mình không chơi theo kiểu ngày
nha mấy ông không bảo là lại bắt chước
còn như hội cũng là mình chơi kiểu ngay
nhá không không không không không thấy
mình sẽ làm như thế nào thì ở đây mình
sẽ có khái niệm là mình sẽ lấy tất cả
các giá trị khi mình lấy từ cơ sở liệu
da mình biến nó thành
thì mình sẽ xử lý từng đối tượng đấy để
mà hiển thị ra đúng đối tượng của mình
nó giống như là gái cái bài này mấy ông
nhớ hôm đấy ông ạ cứ nói tôi bỏ qua vụ
chế biến tôi chưa cốt bộ chế biến còn
hôm nay tôi mới bắt đầu dạy mày ông về
cốt về vụ chị biển đây giả sử là Bê Tô
đặt
Tôi đặt mượt 10 miếng sushi không ạ thì
tức là ông lấy ra rồi ông chế biến nó có
phải chế biến đủ 10 miếng sushi đấy rồi
ông trà với tôi ý nghĩa người miếng
sushi đã được chế biến chống lại 10
miếng thịt sống nó không ạ thì thì mày
ông sẽ phải chế biến cái đoạn chế biến ở
đây tất cả gì những đoạn này ông sẽ phải
xử lý tất cả những cái dữ liệu khi mà
lấy ra ông sẽ phải xử lý rất là dữ liệu
đấy thì tôi sẽ ở đây tôi sẽ có một mà
thôi cho Mạnh làm à trống này xong rồi
tôi sẽ xử lý lỗi tất về tất cả sự liệu
này Như vậy tổng dữ liệu một sẽ xử lý
như thế nào tôi sẽ tôi như tôi đã nói là
tôi sẽ cậu sẽ ép từng cái dữ liệu này
thành một cái đối tượng thành để một cái
ô trách đối tượng để mà tôi xử lý nó
ghét sét đúng như thế này thì tôi sẽ làm
như sao
Ừ tôi sẽ khai báo ở đây thường là cơ thể
nhiều người dạy ở sẽ gộp chung vào trong
thằng lát lớp này nhưng mà tôi sẽ tôi sẽ
tách ra để mấy ông về sau mới ông sẽ
hiểu hơn sẽ có lớp rách như thế này tôi
sẽ là tên nó nó trách mấy ông hiểu được
nó thằng này nó thằng đối tượng này mình
sẽ Clash of track này
đây và ở đây tôi sẽ tạm để nó là mất
nick à
tên như thế này Tại sao lại Cốc đích thì
tí tí đó sẽ dịch đây
vụ va chạm trường hợp này tôi sẽ Huy
quay chắc chắn cho tôi sẽ Ly cái Hoàng
Lớp object này với chị sẽ đi quay lớp có
trách ở ngay trên này
khi đó vợ tôi sợ tôi sẽ là
từng thằng nhóc check này
Bằng News love Taught này à
ạ sau đó I love Black Sun extract mình
sẽ gọi đến mã mình sẽ chuyển đổi dâu
tại mã và này À quên hai có cả họ nữa
đâu mà họ này à
ở
đây là họ này
a hrt này ạ
sau đó tiếp theo thì mình sẽ chuyển vào
trong cái mảnh là cái đối tượng này như
thế này và tôi sẽ trả về cái mạnh vào
đây như thế này chúng tôi không trả lời
cái chả phải dữ liệu thô lấy từ Xperia
nữa mà tôi sẽ tạo mảng mới tới lưu lại
tất cả các Track Đấy và tôi trả lời cái
mạng ấy trách đương nhiên là bây giờ nó
biến áp rét rồi nên là khi mà Inax bên
này ông gọi thì anh sẽ không gọi thôi cả
là mạng này nữa mà ông muốn gọi thông
tin có trách thì cũng sẽ về gọi thì cậu
ngay cái rụng giờ sửa đây là mã này bà
đề tên này ạ
vẫn thế mà Mấy ông thư ra mấy ông muốn
bảo là chúng thế thì em vẫn phải truyền
nó kiểu họ tên như này mình vẫn lấy được
đúng ạ Em vừa mất công đổi nói đối tượng
để làm gì không ạ nhưng mà cái này bạn
chất nó vẫn chưa hoàn hoàn chỉnh về việc
là ghét mà cái tôi bảo cái cái thứ nhất
là cái này khi mà truyền dữ liệu vào như
thế này thì mới ông đang Xét xét tất cả
đặt đặt đó Chị vào chứ không phải lấy ra
còn mấy ông muốn ghét lấy ra thì bây giờ
tôi sẽ khai báo một cái hàm ở đây tôi sẽ
topic xong trận này
như tôi bảo là hàng này còn công khai để
gọi được ở bên này gọi ở ngoài được sẽ
to tích phóng trình là ghét tên nghe
chắc ạ về
bản chất Note ông có thể là ghét họ tên
đi
như này bản chất là mình sẽ Return
direset họ số ông thể nối chỗ ở đây nữa
một cái gì đó sử gạch ngang vẫn được rồi
đưa jt như thế này Cái doris ở đây là gì
đó giết để trong trường hợp này chính là
cái thằng thằng gọi đến hành flash này
và lấy lấy cái thuộc tính của nó sẽ
Gmail của nó là lấy mấy cái ở trên ở Sài
Bào Ngư này cái đoạn này nó rất khó hiểu
lúc đầu nhưng mà về sau ông làm thì ông
sẽ coi nó như một điều hiển nhiên thôi
Ừ đúng rồi Nếu mà Mấy ông chưa gặp em
thì cái đó đã Chúng tôi khẳng định được
tôi cũng dậy hết sức có thể rồi đây ghét
họ bê tông ông đấy họ t ông sẽ không gọi
kiểu ngày nữa mình sẽ gọi kiểu như này
có đến Hàm vest họ tên như này đây lấy
được Họ tên về
đó như thế này cái này nó sẽ tiện ở điểm
là về sau là sử là rất nhiều chỗ ông in
ra họ tên ông muốn hai gái giấu ở giữa
này thành bất kì cái gì ông muốn đúng
không ạ đánh dấu phẩy hai dấu chấm thì
đó giống kiểu bên Tây ngày rồi chấm gái
thì ông chỉ còn sửa ở đúng ở mỗi cái chỗ
xử lý khi toàn bộ những cái view mà đang
gọi đến hàng này nó sẽ đều đồng loạt ở
sửa để tác dụng của việc à
có tác dụng việc làm Lập trình hướng đối
tượng tán chị ông sửa xử lý ở chỗ là
những chỗ khác nó sẽ được heo
bài hát tôi vợ tôi thấy có một Popstar
nữa à
à à
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra cái này tôi mới mấy
ông vẫn thấy tôi mới đang làm ghét chứ
Tôi vẫn chưa làm cái xét thì cả đúng
không cái sét là đều đã giá trị vào ấy
thì bản chất là bản chất chuẩn của Làm
làm cái Lập trình hướng đối tượng mày
thì ông sẽ phải là ghét sét đầy đủ cho
nó chứ không phải kiểu ông sẽ không gọi
được trực tiếp cái thuộc tính theo kiểu
Brit trưởng ngày mà tôi thường sẽ phải
làm như thế này nó Private như thế này
cơ
à Mà ông thấy ở đây rồi cao của tôi có
cảnh báo thì thường là nó sẽ yêu cầu là
ông phải ông phải khai báo kiểu dữ liệu
này nữa là sự kiểu dựng điện thoại kiểu
là số này chuỗi này chủ ấy hiểu nghe này
lại kịp cậu như này cơ
tôi sẽ phải làm cái vụ ghét sét cho tất
cả là ngày thì cách để mà làm két đúng
rồi Nó là kiểu để mà mếu không tự tiện
truy cập được vào dự định vào cái Aptech
kiểu như này để mà sửa xóa nó AD mà sửa
hay thay đổi nó thì ông sẽ phải
máy tạo hàm két sắt riêng đây thì
cho tôi thường ai tạo cái phím tắt trong
cái thằng vs code Đấy hỏng vé cốt thì nó
có ghét sét làm nhanh lắm nhưng mà thằng
thằng pê sô mà tôi không nhớ là tôi có
hay không ngờ tôi tưởng tôi vừa rồi tôi
thử tạo cái này mấy ông vào Xếp tinh
Nhấn vào like template này rồi tạo một
cái like Tablet mới Tôi sẽ gọi cái Hàn
này là cờ set kiểu ngày ghét em xét này
à
ở tp Style ở ông có mơ gì
Cái này tác dụng vào gì để cái này để hỗ
trợ viết tắt tôi thử viết tắt bằng miệng
sẽ hiểu tôi sẽ có pin cái nào đó đây ở
đây sẽ prix ong trên này
khái niệm là dùng cái kiểu như này
khai báo một cái gì đó kẽm ngay
ghét thì mình sẽ suy tôn đôla ĐT
họ đến
cái đúng cái thằng này còn Nghe xa lạ và
tôi đã tên này có luôn đi còn mấy ông dễ
hiểu có luôn
khám xét
thì mình sẽ truyền một cái biến vào
trong này và bạn chất là thằng này nó sẽ
bằng đúng cái tiền đấy như này à
này tôi sẽ đi file nó là trong mọi file
pp là có thể viết tắt được như này
ở đó đây tôi thử lưu lại rồi mấy ông thử
Tôi xem tôi gõ nhé giúp đỡ giờ Xét này
Tab ra cái sau đó thì Mã như thế này nó
xong này tiếp theo lại xét đây là họ này
phải làm thủ công những cái này để mà
khi mà ông truyền giá trị vào như thế
này cũng sẽ không được phép truyên
truyền vào mấy cái thằng quay viết như
này nữa đấy đấy tác dụng của cây viết
này ông không tự tiện được gọi nó mong
sẽ phải gọi đến cái hàm để mà để mà
truyền dữ liệu vào cho nó như thế này
thì tất cả ông sẽ phải sửa lại đây nó sẽ
là Oh jak
tại họ này
em mặc Ờ để mã trước cũng nghỉ mà nha à
mã họ tên đó như thế này
ê ê dororo miệng ở đâu ạ
số đo như thế này sau đó thì bên này ông
không được phép tự tiện gọi đến cái
thuộc tính của nó như thế này ông sẽ là
ghét mã này
còn trong thực này ông có thể ghét họ
ông ghét tên nhưng trong Thử người ông
thấy ghét họ tên thì cũng khai báo hết ở
trong như thế này để khi ông lấy ra có
kết quả nó sẽ như này thôi nhưng mà về
sau khi mà ông muốn xử lý do sự ông muốn
ghép mã giả sự Thế có muốn quét mã ở đây
chẳng hạn bao muốn thêm vé số ở gặp A
cái dấu như này trước nha Chẳng hạn cho
nó lâu đúng ạ
Ừ cái tôi tôi còn dùng cả cái á
Ừ tôi có cài đặt thêm cái để mà chỉnh
cho nó đây
em có chỉnh thêm cái gọi là size
ở Costa lal chọn pp này xong rồi tôi
chọn set for này tôi chọn lauriel cây
cái cosin này để cho khi và tôi ẩn di
format lại cost-free format lại cốt nhé
Thì toàn bộ kiểu nó sẽ tự động Tab cho
ông hay tự động kiểu chỉnh lại cho ông
Toàn bộ kiểu dấu toàn bộ dấu mày cái dấu
hỏi thẳng hàng ấy vẫn rất nhiều cái đấy
thì mày Ông thấy có thể ở đang liền liền
thế này nhá Tôi ấn phím cái nó sẽ hiểu
rồi ra này trong đẹp hơn hẳn đấy ví dụ
điển hình cái này tôi rất khó chịu của
hai a cạnh nhau rồi ạ Ẩn phát là nó sẽ
đều lại cho tôi kiểu nha nó khái niệm
khi format
vs tốt có mấy thằng Nói chung là thằng à
sao với Tech những con có mà
đấy thì bây giờ nó sẽ tự động ra như này
ai đấy Cái cái vụ tác dụng của các set
là như thế đó là nó nó sẽ kiểu à
thì nó sẽ kiểu truyền truyền vào là một
chuyện nhưng mày in ra là chuyện khác
thậm chí về sau giả sử về sau ông Khi mà
ông muốn lưu lại một cái gì đó giống như
là beto chuẩn bị dậy ông cái lưu chẳng ạ
thì ông sẽ thấy là mình lưu lại mình có
thể truyền thêm một vài cái nữa trước
khi lưu cũng được Để tác dụng của việc
Lập trình hướng đối tượng
uống kia ngồi cãi nhau ngôn ngữ lập
trình nào hơn ngôn ngữ nào ạ Thế là dở
rồi
nào hơn mỗi nào ấy chứ
Ừ cái này không quan trọng Thực ra tôi
Tôi Da thịt pp nhưng mà tôi cũng khẳng
định tôi rất FTP nhiều cái chính về
những cái kiểu ví dụ trong Java nó sẽ
không chuyện mà kiểu khai báo khai báo
vừa rồi là public xong rồi trò thẳng đến
xong rồi truyền giá trị và được như thế
đâu thằng ra và báo lỗi ngay đấy à
áo vest vừa set 2 hai cái đấy nó không
quan trọng lắm Vì vậy các bạn thì
cho
em biết trước cái nào nó vẫn được gọi
thôi mà
Thì tôi em nói giờ ấy thì thì nếu lập
trình viên nào mà có nhiều năm kinh
nghiệm rồi và sự ko hiểu rõ thế thì sẽ
thấy mỗi ngôn ngữ là liều mạng người một
cái mạnh thế mạnh riêng và con Trọng ở
ông dùng nó trong việc gì Giả sử tôi
đang làm một cái web tương đối cũng kiểu
bây giờ cái tê một phần nó cũng nhanh
lên rồi chứ hồi trước TP nó chậm hơn đấy
thì nếu mà một trong cách cơ bản thì mấy
ông nên dùng pp còn về còn những cái
trang web mà không cần phải ví dụ là tốc
độ load rất nhanh sau dù dữ liệu là rất
lớn là sự lên tới hàng tỉ gái chẳng hạn
thì chắc chắn là ông nên phải dùng cái
ngôn ngữ khác để nói nhanh và mạnh hơn
giống kiểu ra pha hay là giống kiểu
synap hay là gì gì đó ạ bây giờ Pai nó
nhanh tương đối rồi nè bây giờ vẫn còn
đang được dùng thêm chứ hồi trước thì
công ty tôi là cư nhảy liên tục ngôn ngữ
luôn Ví dụ là hồi trước lúc đầu là p
thuần nhá sao sau nói về sau xử lý dữ
liệu nặng quá thì thì Pepe chỉ làm những
cái thao tác đơn giản vẫn là mở file và
bác em nhưng mà chị làm đơn giản Còn đâu
những cái gì khó thì sẽ gọi về bên Sapa
nhá sợ sau đó thì về sau nữa thì pp nó
lót vẫn trận ở firenze nên là lại chuyển
sang dùng phê word ra Speed để mà chạy
file nhé Thì lúc đấy đâu có nghĩa là cái
ngôn ngữ nào mạnh hơn ngôn ngữ nào đâu
Nó sẽ mảnh trong một vài tình huống rồi
đúng không Lúc đấy Chẳng ai hiểu vì cái
tôi được Tao chỉ chuyên pp Thôi tao sẽ
không Cốt bằng cái khác ừ thế rồi ông ạ
đúng con người chưa trả ok à
à à
ừ ừ
đối xong mỗi cái hiển thị để giờ đã thấy
rất là nhiều file rồi ngọn cốt rất dài
nhưng mà yên tâm tí mình sẽ cốt thêm sẽ
rất là ngắn để để trong sẽ không hoạt
lắm đâu bảo tôi sẽ thử cho ông làm tình
thêm thêm đi cho tôi sẽ có thể à Đấy bấm
thêm
nhớ đến file nào khác nên là hỏi chấm
thôi
bị sẽ vì sẽ truyền thêm ví dụ là mình sẽ
đã chân đồng nhôm cho Bảo Trân sẽ là
crash là tạo chẳng ạ Thế mới không ạ
thêm cái gì đó
nó bấm vào đây thì bây giờ trong trường
hợp này thì router sẽ phải là lấy được
cái chân lại về sau đó thì nó sẽ không
gọi nách nữa họ sẽ phải gọi đến Glass
chẳng hạn thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào
thì đây mình sẽ là mình sẽ có chân bằng
đôla get osen song trường hợp mà có xin
thôi còn nếu mà không có chân để hướng
nhiều nó sẽ không được báo lỗi như thế
này không ạ thì mình sẽ hỏi chấm 1 chấm
đây thức à Nếu mà có cái này lấy về
không thì mình sẽ mặc định là mình sẽ
cho nó lấy nét cũng được như thế này đấy
Ừ thì 11 là ông Áp dụng cái cũ mà tôi
từng là đó nếu không có thể chơi Dò xích
cây để mấy ông kiểm tra trường hợp sai
nữa là sự như này
á tên là nếu mà cây là Index thì mình sẽ
gọi đến nó như thế này
cách như thế này còn để phô sẽ là
em ạ defoe sẽ là cậu ấy cho nhập sai rồi
biết được có một cái con tách tắt hơn mà
ông thử nhé tôi có thể truyền thẳng như
thế này đó
đấy thì nó vẫn không thay đổi nó không
thay đổi bản chất là cái biến áp chân
này nó sẽ hiểu đây là chuỗi mà và sẽ
hiểu là gọi đến hà mát chân Hối trong
Nghìn Ngày công nhận là cậu bé uống thấy
hơi bị đau não một tí không ạ à
các em à nhìn thấy tôi đỡ phải có phốt
Thấy tiện lắm à
đây trong trực thì trong chùa press thì
vọng sẽ giống hệt như thế này
thì bấm vào thì sẽ gọi đến Hàm press chữ
tôi không phải mất công kiểu dạng như
hôm trước như mọi khi đó là kiểu nó sẽ
đây press này
led kiểu ngay à
em ở đâu next này sau đây Index này họp
không cần rõ và hai này giống hệt nhau
mà đúng không Hay mình như thế thì như
tôi vào đấy chuyển biến ở trên nó trong
như thế này Thế sao
Bây giờ tôi sẽ tạo hàm great ở trong lớp
controller đúng không ạ đỏ ngay nếu
không sẽ thấy cái ID của tôi đang báo
cảnh báo thôi là là kiểu là bản chất
thẳng hàng ngày nó không trả về 0 trả
lời cái gì cả đúng không nó không trả về
cái gì cả thì mình nên thường hay có
thêm voi đây để hiểu là cái phong chân
nó không không trả lời gì cả nhà tôi sẽ
tạm bỏ qua mấy vụ đấy
anh ở đây thì mặc led thế mới thì bản
chất là mình không cần gọi gì cả thì sẽ
chị gọi đến view là class thôi
a
crash đ.tp này mẹ sẽ có 1 form này
ở đây là họ họ cho lớp Ok
ở đây là
anh không Tôi nhớ là để cho đề for là là
ba ngày rồi nếu tôi có thể bỏ qua họ đi
đỡ nhập họ
300 thôi rồi có nhập đi nhập đi để mà tí
đó làm xét cho thử tiện đã thay này bằng
cách
nha
mình sẽ có tên này
một tuần là
chấm a Trần Bằng
Store là lưu lại này
mắt hết là post này đó
thì nó sẽ ra ngay khi mà gọi itranslate
chị sẽ hiển thị ra cái pho lại thêm sẽ
là
thì cô đi à
cô cô
à à
anh ăn thêm này
bạn trong trường hợp này à
lỗi phải địa phố sai đúng nhập sai
Action rồi
đấy trong trường hợp này do mình chưa
khai báo Nhã Trần trong cái này nó sẽ
báo lỗi không ạ sẽ lại thêm rồi đấy bạn
cái như này nữa nó đương nhiên là trong
lớp controller mình lại phải tạo thêm
một cái phương trình là store đó ngoại
cái có bị nhược điểm ấy nó không hề
không thằng ie nó không hiểu được cái
bìa đã chuyện này của ông đang là gì
không thông báo được là cái cái phương
trình này tồn tại không nó khác với kiểu
dạng nếu không khai báo rồi Như này
thì cái ông sẽ hiểu là cái phong trần
không tồn tại và xử như thế này Cản ạ
Đấy nó sẽ thông báo hộ ông mà ngày nó
không tồn tại và nó thêm hộ cho ông kiểu
như này đấy nhưng mà do là ông làm chỗ
tắt quá như này thì thằng Nhi không đủ
thông minh này nó hiểu được cho như này
Ok chưa anh
ấy thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ nói qua về mấy
cái tác dụng của Israel để mấy ông bớt
bớt dùng spytech chuyển qua dần cái cái
cái cái này là anh nói chung chưa mở một
APEC tôm nhá bé cốt thấy các từ ngọn Như
Nhau Thôi
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình mình làm cái vụ lưu
lại thì bản chất là mình sẽ làm là mình
như tôi đã được bà là mình controller sẽ
là hoàng nhận cái nào nhân viên đấy sẽ
thằng nhận nhận request những cái yêu
cầu sau đó thì sẽ làm gì sẽ đưa lại
những cái đấy cho thằng mua đồ để thẳng
mua đồ mà lưu lại ngoại
mình sẽ là họ à họ bằng đôla ghét họ này
post nhà
sau đó khi tôi sẽ lại gọi đến nó như thế
này
thì đây
cái hàng này không phải Hà mô nữa không
phải lấy tất cả về không cho mày mình sẽ
là lưu lại đúng ạ Ông có thể khai báo
hàng này như nào tùy Tôi tưởng ai sai
bảo hành này Hà Mi xuất sẽ hiểu nói rõ
vào
Hôm nay tôi sẽ thấy bảo hành này
nick mà nó lại ít sợ nha
store này nên là chung của thằng control
led này cũng thế Index nhãn thế nhưng mà
những cái hàm kiểu như này lại là hàm
chung của bên mua đồ nên là tôi sẽ khai
báo kiểu ý giấc hoa Glass Tôi sẽ đặt tên
no class được
Anh ở đối với Neville tên của hàm the
Glass đây tôi sẽ tên nó class nhé hiểu
để về sau nhìn somerville ông thấy hà
Mày Ông quay lắm ông ạ sẽ flash như thế
này
em không cần trả về cái gì cả Nói chuyện
muốn truyền vào họ này tên này rồi gọi
được đến Hàm Blade là sẽ hiểu là truyền
hai cái này vào sẽ lấy được ngày chẳng
hạn
thì đây chuyện họ tên là cho mày và bây
giờ mình sẽ làm ở gì mình sẽ copy cái
đoạn này ạ
cho tôi sẽ chuyện Họ vào trong này
à à
thủ đô la họ này và đây xét tên này đưa
tên này sau đó thì tôi sẽ gọi tôi sẽ
muốn kiểu nhà sẽ là
Insert hoặc như tôi bảo
kiểu này đi hiểu Khi mà truyền giá trị
vào xong rồi gọi Asus thì nó sẽ dẫn
[âm nhạc]
ở Thượng Hải sẽ khởi tạo đối tượng này
khi truyền vào này
vụ này đang hơi không biết là nên đoạn
này nên giải thích trong bé ông như Nam
Á
anh
Bởi vì nếu mà gọi hay bị sốt thì ra
thằng này không đúng lắm
cái đây nhá
cầu SG bình thường sẽ lại Insert into
love ngay đúng không Họ này tên này ba
lưu cho nó như này à
mình sẽ lại là
ô check
ở đây đoạn này
có gì thế Không không cần phải gọi Hà
mint nhà đâu ở đây mình sẽ gọi đến là
ghét
I get họ này
thì tôi sẽ chuyển qua dùng cái
mấy ông sẽ biết được là nó giống ra
Speed là ông sẽ có thể dùng cái dấu như
thế này và ông có thể
Uh cho nó vào như này để ông gọi được
cái hàm ghét họ ở trong cái chuỗi như
thế này để ông ạ Chú Báo Màu gì nhỉ
cái này nó đang bảo liên quan đến bảo
mật bỏ qua nhé
tiếp
thấy cái đoạn này sẽ rất là phức tạp hơn
so so so với cái xong rồi cái cậu đồ ăn
hột ông đã từng là đó sao bạn ấy ông chỉ
cần có biến họ có biển tên rồi không ạ
Mấy ông chuyên thẳng và thôi Tại sao Tại
sao ở đây ở mất công ở xét vào này xong
gọi ghét ra như thế này đúng không ạ
nhưng mà Lập trình hướng đối tượng như
tôi đã bảo nó là như thế nghĩa là có thể
ông truyền lên là họ Nhưng mà như trong
trường hợp này nữa đâu khi mà ông kết ra
Ông ấy ông ấy lấy nó ra theo kiểu ôm một
lời nó ra cái cổ khác thì sao đấy
anh không xét vào và ông lấy ra nó có
thể là màn kiểu khác nếu không sẽ phải
làm theo kiểu như này à
đã theo theo kiểu là xét vào xong lấy ra
đúng kiểu như này đấy tìm được ốc chế
cái tôi đi sang cả nó xin lỗi
đó này
Ừ nếu mà ghét như này có khi ở bị nhầm
sang Ghét cả cái vụ ghét
hết tên ghét họ tên ghét ghét để in ra
mắt
sử dụng giống kẹo ghét cái này
chuẩn mà mình sẽ lưu đại là xét xét này
sau đó thì mình sẽ họ đến thằng
ở tại mình phải gọi như này thôi à
sẽ phải gọi nó như thế này mới đúng chứ
không phải gọi handset nữa Ghét nữa
Nhưng nếu tao chửi mày thì cái thằng này
đang là pate nên không gọi được rất
thích kiểu nghe à
cho sức khỏe nha
à à
làm theo kiểu là tôi sẽ phải ốp toàn bộ
những cái Hàn này
lên lên đây rồi à
đây cho chuẩn đi
xóa lại đi
à à
bí
shall chúng ta thế lấy vậy Chính thằng
bạn thân này
không không khai báo cái lên đầu được
một vì có lúc thì không không gọi thằng
mua đồ mà Có phải trường hợp nào gọi mua
đồ đó Đợi mình tí cái đoạn này đáng lẽ
là đợt này mình sẽ phải gọi đền á
sơ đồ logic
có một đoạn này thì lấy được họ tên rồi
để tôi thử nhé mã How equally này
lại video này
nó
báo lỗi đôla Thọ ổ dòng 19 đợi thì
lên mà nó Đợi tí nhé
cho nên này à
qua hôm nay tôi nghĩa nó dễ hiểu hơn năm
trước và các bạn học học cái này xanh
xanh Lazio thì nó sẽ dễ hiểu hơn nữa vì
nó Cốt nó sẽ
cho mọi nhà cốc nào chị ngắn hơn nữa Và
thậm chí là tôi học xong học sau cái Ok
này thì nếu người sang ngôn ngữ khác nó
sẽ như thế thôi Ngôn ngữ nào nóng có Ok
rửa nhà nó Lập trình hướng đối tượng lập
tiếng chung cho mọi rất nhiều ngôn ngữ
tả lại cha mày chẳng ạ ạ
như thế này
xin lỗi à
anh em ạ con ếch này à
yêu cầu truy vấn lỗi sai rồi nhé
Ừ đợi tí nhé sẽ xa lộ này chai cho em ra
sao ạ
à à
anh như thế người ta không cần gọi kiểu
này nữa
họ chuyện ngay thôi
đó đổ lại đồ đấy
a http khó tôi thấy ra khó hơn pp này
còn dễ đấy à
Ừ ok đánh chạy được gọi cái này là chả
tôi phải gộp chung phòng mua đồ chứ
không tách được riêng Model kiểu kia tôi
muốn tách nó ra cho mấy ông đỡ bị choáng
với file này nó sẽ thành rất là dài
nhưng có vẻ là vẫn phải dùng phải dùng
chính bản thân nó để tôi tôi muốn ở đây
là gì Tôi muốn Xét xét vào đây bởi vì
hoàn toàn xét ở đây Tôi có thể truyền
thêm giờ sửa Tôi muốn ông không quan tâm
cái họ của ông truyền vào gì Tôi muốn
thêm chữ nghĩa là trong như này trả lại
đúng không ta sửa một chuyện hết như thế
này tôi tải lại trang đó thì mặc định và
Hà
Nội à Bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình
tĩnh nha
nhà
miễn phí có đúng rồi nghỉ
tại sao không vào được nhỉ
Ừ cái câu truy vấn đấy có vẻ lỗi lỗi gì
đó rồi this option tô
à chạy thử nhé ạ
lỗi này liên quan đến nữa xe tự nhiên đã
biến thành Latinh
đó chưa phải là cốt kp lỗi
ờ ờ sang bên level thì nó sẽ bắt cho
mình cái trường hợp nếu mà cậu ép cao
ông có lỗi chứ không phải kiểu bị như
này à
Tôi thường phải ốp cả Cuộn mình đi nào
lại tôi tạm rồi đi nha
ra không Không được trên không trên được
này báo là liên quan cái gì
không đổi được à Tôi tạm giúp cái cột họ
đi tôi tạo lại của họ nhé
đó có Legends
ý là
như này Lưu vậy tiếng Việt có dấu đúng
không Đó cho tôi
vì sợ vợ tôi bỏ cái đài đi này đi Sốt
lại
ở đó
ý nghĩa làm chỉ là bây giờ khi em khi ở
Tôi muốn lưu lại tôi thêm bất kì cái gì
cũng được thì thì khi mà khi mà mình
trong trong cái việc trong cái phone của
mình thì mình không mặc định là mình
thêm chữ đời đâu đúng không Nhưng ở khi
mình muốn lưu lại mình thêm một cái gì
thì mình chỉ cần sửa trong thằng mua đồ
nào có như là khi ở miệng lưu cái gì đó
là nó sẽ tự động thêm cho mình cái kiểu
như thế tác dụng của nó nghỉ hết đó
đi tìm mấy ông xem lại
ở lớp ak18 Đợi tí phải xóa cái thằng lớp
Jack
ở
đây nó sẽ là phiên yourself tức à sao Tớ
là bạn thân có thể là doris cũng được
cái là chính nó xèo cái gì trong trở về
đó giống nhau
đón như thế này miễn nhạc
xét là lấy giá trị truyền vào xong rồi
in ra mà
chồng hơi bữa xét này đúng nhỉ xét xếp
vào
Ừ ừ nó vẫn ông ấy vẫn đúng không Tao
theo quy tắc của Ok thì nó vẫn đúng nhá
Chồng nhậu buồn cười thôi nguyễn nguyễn
ý
anh
vẫn đúng theo quy tắc của Poppy nhá Cái
này nhìn mấy ông nhìn này rồi không xa
nhá đi nhưng mà đương nhiên là thằng
burial nó sẽ nó sẽ tinh chỉnh cho ông
việc là phong lưu lại việc ông xét nó
khác cũng giờ khi mà ông hiển thị ra là
khác Còn đây là tôi đang gộp chung hai
Hà mà một Nếu thấy hàm này vừa để mà lưu
lại cũng vừa để mà lấy ra nữa mình đang
ở trong nó hơi buồn cười rồi ngay nhưng
mà Đây tôi nói qua giọng bé ông ấy ông
hiểu về tác dụng của ké thôi là tội
không chắc là tôi lắm cái đoạn này nó
hâm ý lắm đã phải tạo thêm Hàn vậy mà đi
lại và một hàng được lấy ra cơ à
anh nói chung một đoạn này Tôi tin là
đoạn này mấy ông cũng hiểu lá về việc
không không tôi tôi không nắm chắc phải
xử lý đâu Thôi mà dậy nữa cho mấy ông
nghĩ hết
nhà tôi làm sao đoạn Open này nọ ok này
vẫn chạy được vẫn đúng rồi hơi phức tạp
một tí đúng phút tầm tí thôi nhưng đại
khái nó thế Nó là kiểu Mình sẽ lưu lại
tất cả mấy cái này Private mình không
được phép cho lên trực tiếp với ông cài
ahbu này mà mình sẽ phải thông qua những
cái hàm ghét sét để mà lấy thông tin ra
Kiểu kiểu như thế này để mình in ra kết
quả như thế
Ừ thì bây giờ ờ
Ừ cái vụ sửa xóa được ra bị lại rất là
nhanh Nếu không phải ông hiểu qua cái
này rồi mà làm chứ anh anh để tối thụ
cho mấy hôm qua về sự nốt sửa xóa nhé
đấy
nó dễ mà
trà
sữa này đây mình sẽ là một cái thẻ à
chân bằng Adidas
xỏ kim mã ở
biết mã chả
ở đây sẽ sữa
vậy nha Bấm vào đây sẽ ra truyền Mã
Hình như tôi đã nói em trường hợp hơi
sai gửi khuyến mãi của tôi đang đang lấy
luôn vừa để in ra kể cái này là vừa để
in ra vừa để kiểu gì đó nó này ra đã bị
như này Nếu không có thể tạo hẳn hàm mới
dụ hàm sâu mã kiểu nhà ở để mà hiển thị
in ra còn lúc mà lấy ra thì ông chỉ muốn
lấy ra thông như này thôi nó sẽ khác đây
cái để mà in ra nó sẽ như thế này con
cái lấy Thực sự nó sẽ nghe các em ạ
Đây tôi ta lại này cái này vẫn như này
nha thì bấm vào cái này để in dao cái
lấy này
mình thấy liên tục dễ mà trước mấy ông
cứ nghĩ nó khó lắm à nào ông sẽ ngừng
tiếp thu cũng sẽ phải luôn nghĩ là nó dễ
chẳng qua mình mình mới mới gặp mình sẽ
bị thoáng Chắc chắn rồi anh kể cả Thiên
Tài nữa mới gặp không bảo hiểu hết làm
như chuyện đấy A anh chẳng nghĩ thoáng
quan trọng vào kiểu mấy ông phải nghĩ là
nó dễ để học thì mấy ông ấy học từ nạn
thôi
a cho tôi sẽ tạo thêm một cái nó là Ella
không ạ sẽ tạo thêm một cái trong này
nữa làm cái đít
một cái phong Chân hãy phong trần
edit mặt rất là mình sẽ à
Ừ đúng rồi đúng rồi giống như anh còn
làm đấy Ghét mã để mà lấy ra giá trị
thật còn có thể dùng những hàm khác tạo
thêm hẳn hàng mới để in ra thì dùng cái
ghét thế xét cái họ sẽ họ này thì dặn
thế xét họ này đúng nhá sẽ họ này lưu
lại là đúng nha để ghét họ lấy ra thì
được à
xét Đáng lẽ nó phải khác khác một tí
ở đây là gì
Tôi sẽ cần ở đây là tôi sẽ truyền mãi ở
trong này mà tôi sẽ gọi hàng này hàng
Pha tất cả phải là tìm tìm tìm một thằng
nào đó sẽ có lớp ở đây chả vậy mà thằng
nào đó ở lớp à sẽ phải bảo đây ít đi em
sẽ có một khác đấy lại lại tạo phạm file
đúng không
I know the copy từ Hà mô này bởi nó khá
giống nhau Copy xuống đây này
a
fine này ở đây sẽ ra truyền mãi ở trong
này lại điệp khúc máy kia đi con nít này
đây
Where nhé Mấy ông Thực ra chuẩn là mấy
ông sẽ lại khởi tạo cái này tiếp đây mấy
cũng phải khởi tạo con này đi mà ở
khi xét mã vào chỗ mới quay thôi mã đấy
thôi Cứ thẳng ngay đi
à à
dự án xử à không cần phải xét gì ở đây
cả truyền thẳng Ba Nhưng mà khi lấy ra
đây ông vẫn phải biến nó thành đối tượng
kiểu gì mà ông ấy lại biến nó hình tượng
Từ đây ông sẽ có trả về cái quả đấy nhá
ông sẽ có
sự tích bằng
máy kéo reflect này rồi
mạng này đi này à
mình sẽ trả lời chính lão chết này đó
thế xong xong đấy
cho mình mình sẽ trả về cái thằng đối
tượng mà đối tượng nó sẽ trả về đây rồi
mình sẽ trả về một cái view
là thế này edit à
thì
mình sẽ đăng ký kết cái thằng ngày thành
ellis này các bạn chất ở đây mình sẽ
value cho nó
cái bên indie
hết tên này
cậu ngay à
à à
ừ ừ
họ ông kêu đang hỏi cái gì đấy
hai lần nên em
La La Mã này alo cho nó cũng là đô la x
tại
ghét mã này
đổi đề update này à
đó kiểu Nha và bây giờ mình có thể sửa
nó thoải mái với ngay Xóa đoạn này đi
Vì sao ấn sửa khi sex à thả mình khai
báo lại điệp khúc ở đây update này
em copy đấy Ở đây mình có chuyên chở về
dữ liệu sẽ copy đoạn trên này đi
chỉ
có thế mạnh nữa
vào đổi đề là hàm update
khi đăng nhập ở đúng rồi nó sẽ là hàng
ăn hết
là mã này họ tên kiểu ngay à
ib2 Minh lại tôi sẽ lại có Pinterest này
Cái đây là update này
đây mình chuyển đô la mã sao
mình lại xét Mã
khi mã này
sau đó đi update rồi update lớp
xét
họ bằng hack đ
a
tên quét mã này
tôi sẽ chạy bị lỗi Tại sao một cái hàm
ghét họ cái tên này sôi xét một đống ở
như thế này nó sẽ bị lặp lại thêm cái
Ừ nó nó sẽ bị lặp lại cái
họ Nguyễn Tiên như thế
cái thọ lắm lỗi à Tao đợi xem nó bảo lỗi
tại sao một 18 tuổi cột dài phết rồi đến
118 rồi
Anh check ghét họ
thế họ chạy mà nhỉ
anh gọi tí nhé Đợi tôi một tí
ừ ừ
à quên quên quên không cần phải ghét họ
đây chị gọi trai ở họ rồi Quyền Quyền
quyết
cái này xét rồi không cần lại ghét đó
nữa
Xin lỗi Xin lỗi
cho nó
Ừ ok ok
xem thử này
được đấy
Cái Nguyễn này nó cứ làm đi học lại khó
chịu thật bởi cái xét đấy Ok tạm kệ đi
tắm kể tôi chán rồi
nhưng mà yên tâm mà sang L'Oreal thì nó
sẽ đơn giản hơn mấy cái vụ này nó có hàm
tích hợp sẵn nhiều béo ngày hội này thôi
nhưng mà tôi đang dạy cho mấy ông để ông
biết qua Ok mày không phải tao đem mà
mày không làm cốt cái tên thuần hay nhảy
sang ngôn ngữ khác như mấy ông chạy quen
rồi Ok chứ không thì tôi dậy luôn Lara
cho nhanh
đấy thì
khi bé update về mình làm nốt rồi delete
delete thì dễ chẳng cần này ok đấy
I Delete
để xóa đúng không ạ
đã xóa này à
Em bấm vào để xóa này thì mình cần ở đây
lại điệp khúc lại chuyển thêm Đi net ở
đây anh sẽ ra
I love
ở đây sẽ lấy mã về
sẽ gọi hàm delay Thôi tớ đơn giản à
Ừ
nhưng mà không trong lars thì nó sẽ
không gọi thì cậu này sẽ gọi đi trôi
chuyển mã như thế này tên hơi Dị nhỉ Đấy
ở bên này sẽ lại copy đây này
đi cho truyền như thế này
Nghĩa không cần lại xét Ghét thì đâu cần
như này thôi này à
a slack for
love nicewave thẳng dài song I
anh không cần đối tượng gì đây Cái
này thằng như này Ok chạy thử
ở xóm nhỉ không bay bạn thứ tám đúng
không Mã
cập nhật digiphone
toàn bộ về mới C
cho MBC
xong rồi sẽ đấu D
nhưng mà có một cái thứ mà vừa nãy bạn
lớp trưởng có nhắc nó hơi bị khó chịu
một tí là mấy ông thấy nãy giờ có gì là
phải không chính cái đoạn con ếch này là
bạn liên tục thực ra thì cái này cũng mà
có thể biến nó thành đối tượng rồi mình
sẽ gọi lên đối tượng nó
được nó sẽ là như thế này tôi sẽ tạo một
cái biến con nữa nốt nốt nốt nốt này rồi
chúng mày thôi choáng rồi đúng không nốt
đấy mình sẽ lại khởi tạo một thằng đối
tượng kiểu ngay class nó là con ếch ngay
và mình mà tôi thường hay làm là tôi sẽ
à
Uh cho nó 1 cái Thục mấy cái thuộc tính
kiểu ngày và thôn quê nước trước mày có
thuộc tính của nó cậu nghe nhé Tôi sẽ
khai báo Nó là kiểu Nga là
post bằng
này
Tab nữa trong đấy nó đã cả bầy đúng
không
nếu mà ông hạ tạo hàm Thế là con ếch thì
nó sẽ bị báo lỗi vì có nó bị trùng tên
rồi chung có hàm Thế là có nick rồi tôi
sẽ báo hàm kiểu viết tắt thở ngay thôi
tôi sẽ copy cái này xa a
em copy đúng cái này sang này
nhưng mà chọn cho mày thì tôi sẽ
đổi hết toàn bộ mấy cái mấy cái xong này
Xóa toàn bộ này đi này tối độ nó thành
đô loa vip sôi gọi đến đầu tiên à
hotline does it gọi đến buzô này cho rít
gọi đến bass và doris gọi đến tôi bay
như này goroth chính nhà chính là thằng
class này thôi nó chứ Thằng Toàn này sao
gọi đến những cái thuộc tính của nó
sau đó mình sẽ with ơn cái hạn con ếch
nhân này Tại sao bây giờ trong trường
hợp này là sử trong trường của u đã lấy
tất cả mình cần truyền truyền cái quay
vào trong này sau đó thì nó chả với cái
quả mình đúng không thì tôi sẽ
Ừ cái hàng này tôi để nó viết đi tôi sẽ
có một hàm là hàm fabrique ở đây
bản chất cái Hà này nó sẽ chỉ có tác
dụng của như thế này
đầu tiên tôi sẽ vẫn phải có cái con ếch
nó sẽ lấy cái hàm con nách từ đôla rít
gọi đến hik-connect để lấy được cái con
ếch rồi nhé rồi tôi sẽ
có kết quả trả về như này
ở nhà mày rồi nhé sau đó thì tôi lại
đóng cái con ếch à
đứng ở Hàn này tên tôi đặt tên Hà này ở
Hàm snack đi à
ô tô truyền cái có truy vấn là xong đây
này
ở đó rồi trả với quả ở đây này đó thì
bây giờ
cho tôi sẽ chỉ cần xóa các bạn lại đi
này Ừ tôi sẽ đi quay cái thằng con ếch ở
trên cùng như này bởi vì kiểu gì gọi đến
hàng mua đồ hả chị sẽ có bị có kết nối
cơ sở liệu cái gì cũng phải con ếch thôi
à
à à
ở tuổi này sẽ lưu con ếch này
rồi gọi đến Hàm slack trò chuyện cậu
Apple nhà là sau đó không cần may cái A
cloud Nga đóng luôn Tôi thử cho mấy ông
xem nhé
quá Vẫn như thế đúng không đó Nhớ đương
nhiên được thêm sửa xóa bây giờ sẽ sẽ
vọng cũng sẽ phải sửa lại sợ lại hết
đúng không Mình sẽ không khai báo kiểu
nông dân kiểu ngay nữa thì sẽ thay đổi
như thế nào sẽ lại copy cái đoạn này
bạn trong trường hợp này này thì ra mình
cũng phải select mình sẽ cần không cần
trả về cái gì cả tôi sẽ thường đặt tên
hàm skill 1 cái là
có một cái là xà lách Bái về và một cái
xử lý thôi
anh nghe này Đó mình không cần trả được
kết quả như ngày thôi chị ngắn gọn ngay
đó đổi lại skill này đó Xóa toàn bộ các
đoạn ADN
khi cài có trả về cái gì đó đúng không
chị sẽ ra snack
đó xong rồi à
cách xóa máy chơi close
U2 tô cứ thử Xóa hết được mấy ông thử
xem nhé
hôm
nay là skill này
đó để tôi thử chạy lại hết từ đầu mày
ông xem nhé
khi tổn này đúng không Thêm này
ừ ừ
chú chó Đùa đúng không Xóa này
anh
đúng không sửa này
à à
em ở đâu chưa
vào chữ miễn ok đấy Anh nghĩa là đầy đủ
tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa có thể thứ
không rd kết hợp với Mc và cái Oppa Thực
ra thì nó rất là dài so với đồ ăn 1
anh không cần nói xa so đón một nhưng nó
lại dễ sửa hơn so với đồ ăn một Bởi vì
bây giờ mấy ông chỉ cần sửa ở ở đâu nó
sẽ gọi giờ tiện hồn
nó tôi ở nó nhiều file hơn thật ngờ về
sau mấy ông sẽ còn tận dụng được những
cái Hà này nữa quan trọng nhưng nếu một
tận dụng được hàng này nữa Khi mà sang
buổi sau sao mà sang làm tận 2 bảng thận
Thậm chí nhiều bảng nữa Jimmy Ông thấy
là những cái Hà mà vẫn dùng lại được ví
dụ ra sửa vẫn gọi toàn bộ danh sách lớp
thì ông chị còn gọi đấy Tháng 2 Ông
không cần phải kết nối cơ sở liệu hay
làm gì nữa ông gọi đúng cái Hàn này là
chạy bởi vì cái này đã từng làm rồi đấy
nó sự tái sử dụng có được và và dễ đến
sửa bảo trì dễ nâng cấp từ thứ được nữa
đúng không Nói chung là vì cái tác dụng
của cái này nó rất lớn nên là mấy ông
thấy cho dù khó thì mấy ông mày ông mà
theo ngày này Có nên học chứ không ai
làm cốt thuần nữa Nếu Đừng có bảo khó
quá tụi em quay lại cuối tuần không
Không chuyện này đâu nếu không kiểu gì
cũng sẽ phải biết qua cái này có thể
cách dạy của tôi vừa rồi có thể khó hiểu
bởi vì mình không thể tham khảo của các
thầy khác cũng được những các loại khác
tôi thấy à
cá nhân tôi đã xem quay thì mỗi thầy
cũng dậy đâu có một cái khó hiểu riêng
chứ không thể nào mà bảo trận xem cái
hiểu rồi ngay à
khi
mà hàng đương nhiên là nếu mà ông làm đã
học cái này ở trên trường và học ra rồi
thì tôi tin là mấy ông lại thấy tôi nó
nhắc lại một lần nữa thì mới ông ấy cũng
cố được thêm cái nước Nếu tôi Nghĩa
không không lỗi là quá lãng phí ra mình
béo không
buổi hôm nay sao thế thôi của mày sẽ chỉ
thế này thôi Nếu không còn thông báo gì
nhỉ
c D1 danh sách nào đó bằng Loreal trên
làm đơn giản này kiểu lớp vệ sinh viên
nhà được mà
ừ ừ
cho bữa hôm nay tặng kết thúc đấy rồi
nhé có gì thì
em xem lại xem cái này xem đi xem lại đi
bởi vì à Buổi sau nữa tôi sẽ sẽ vẫn sẽ
dùng cái này để mà để mà xanh 2 bảng sau
buổi sau nữa tôi nhảy sang L'Oreal
L'Oreal thì tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy ông dễ
hơn
à à
Thế hả sao để lại Hàm Tên là xé rách à
Thứ ba cách mình là tên Hà nó thế thôi
hàm bên con nít nhà mình là tên là gì
được để mình hiểu là nó trả lời cái giá
trị ở đây thiết kế thêm cái voice hiểu
Nó không trả mấy giá trị này chẳng hạn
cũng được đấy chứ
Ừ anh sang tivi say
stone này mấy ông có thể ấn vào này xuẩn
F2 để mà sửa nhanh cậu nhà chẵn
Ừ thì tất cả chỗ khác nó sẽ được đổi
thực hiện
cho tất cả chỗ khác sử dụng cái hàng
Pizza kiểu nó sẽ được đổi theo ý
này tôi tin à Tôi nhắc lại kiến thức thì
có thể là bạn cũng sẽ hiểu tôi đã nói gì
khi sex
ờ ờ Ok Thôi tạm kết thúc đây nhá chào
bạn nha